So here now is the, current concept definition of arch that the AI program has.
Now, the teacher shows a new example, here is the new example shown. There
are three bricks, but the third brick here, is not on top of the first two.
This is the input to the AI program with a third example. And the teacher tells,
the AI program that this is not a positive example of an arch. So here is
a current concept definition. Here is a representation of the input example, and
information that this is a negative instance of the example.
What may the AI program learn from it?
The AI program must refine it's current definition of the arch, in such a way
that the, new negative example is ruled out. But how can we do that? One way
of doing that is to say, that, we will put extra conditions on these links.
These support links must be there. These are not optional. We'll call it,
the require-link heuristic. This require-link heuristic says that,
if the structure of the presentation of the concept and is structure of
the representation of the, negative example have some things in common.
But there are also some differences. Then revise the current definition, in
such a way that, those things that are not in common become, must be required.